[Music]
Philippines leader Rodrigo Duterte is
unlike any other allied leader we've had
to deal with the alliance between the
Philippines in the United States has
been one of the bedrocks of American
Asian policy particularly up to the
1990s when we had to move out of our
bases there the Obama administration was
right to try to negotiate a new pact
between the Philippines and the United
States to allow US forces to have access
to bases throughout the region
if Duterte continues his move towards
China and if he continues to slow down
the pace of us Philippines military and
other types of cooperation and we have
to think very carefully about how we
bring him back on board if he signs a
formal alliance with China then we need
to declare our alliance over but short
of that we need to be thinking about
ways of responding to his concerns about
domestic development issues so that he
understands that working with us on
regional stability and maritime security
is actually in the interest of the
Philippines above all to learn more
about my take on the risks threatening
Asia's future peace and prosperity check
the links in the description below also
let us know what other topics you'd like
a EEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds